we've got these sorted by popularity
um
let's see what we're getting here how to
become a sigma male
2.5 million okay here's one with 7.7 so
signs you might be a sigma male so we'll
see what we get here
Sigma mail they are known as the rarest
males on Earth which makes them
irresistible to women we used to think
that there was only Okay so
that's one of the talking points that
I've heard too as well is that they are
the rarest form of man on Earth which
makes them irresistible to women
and I'm not buying it because
while it's clear that they exist
women like competent men that have that
have influence right like one of the
things that women like are socially
influential guys and if you're a Hermit
you can't demonstrate that so I don't
buy uh Captain yellow glasses here with
the uh story that they're rare and the
most attractive to women so let's keep
going see what else he says
back it up a tiny bit which makes them
irresistible to women we used to think
that there was only Alpha and beta where
Alphas are at the top and then betas are
at the bottom but sigmas are almost like
a cheat code they are at top with the
alphas but they are outside of the
hierarchy biggest signs that you're a
sigma is that you love being alone but
you still value others sigmas are never
more comfortable than when they are
alone they might be viewed as
introverted and you also value people
close to you but it might be difficult
to establish relationships another sign
you're a sigma is if you treat everybody
the same sigmas reject the idea that you
need to treat one person one way and
other people another way okay I I don't
know where this kid came up with that
because that wasn't in the article that
I just read from the psychologists so
that that doesn't make a lot of sense
but anyway that's that's Tick Tock for
you right that's Bro Science right there
and this could make others dislike you
the last sign is that sigmas are silence
they don't really talk about the little
things in their lives which makes women
naturally find you mysterious and
attractive
here's okay well look I mean mystery is
definitely attractive there's no
question about that
uh so they keep using Christian Bale
here as the original Sigma male
like what is what is this all about how
to become a Signet
okay there's no talking so I'm just
gonna mute the the sound so I don't have
any issue with YouTube
just a dude walking around it's
Christian Bale
now this is this is peaky blinders over
here I don't know if you guys have seen
the series really really good
um
he's definitely not a
Sigma because he has his I mean he's
basically the leader of a gang
so why would they use the image the
imagery here
to Define what a sigma like it like it's
weird like they suck in these Notions
and ideas that don't that don't make a
lot of sense with the Avatar itself
Joker definitely an outcast for sure
and now the thing's freezing up and not
playing of course
anyway let's come back to that in a
second yeah a lot a lot of so apparently
this this like lip movement here is is
Sigma mail stuff
what else we got here personality traits
I don't know
so I asked um
yes on Twitter
Define a known Sigma male where's the
post I did here let me grab it here
so who's an iconic Sigma male that I
would know
so here we go
students learn exactly what a sigma male
is
mgtow actually high value being sent his
own
who are actually high value versus yeah
okay
I would agree with that so this guy Lee
basically is saying a a sigma as a guy
is basically going his own way but he's
chosen that path instead of being sent
his own way sent are the guys that
um want to get something out of society
women you know more specifically
um when you're when you've actually
chosen the path of
um more like a little bit more Solitude
I I guess
then I would definitely you know connect
with that based on what I've come across
Bruce Wayne is a signal male
Izzy though
is he though
because
he definitely had a network even though
he worked alone he still had a network
right he had his Butler he you know
definitely collaborated with quite a few
people I mean you know if you're going
to use that comic book character and
even the movies so I don't know Matthew
McConaughey
is he though or is he just an alpha
that's you know quiet and you know like
he's got a good Network right
somebody put
yeah I'm gonna put these up on the
screen so you can see some of these
um sure screen
this guy over here is a sigma male no
just kidding obviously uh me and do time
John Wick
yeah okay so John Wick
um
probably yes although if you've watched
the films he's of course got a network
of people that he relies on so not
entirely completely independent but
definitely not you know like the Power
Ranger gang you know if you know what
I'm saying Paul Newman I
um I'm a little too you know some people
look at me go oh you're you're old Rich
I'm actually a little bit too young to
remember very many of Paul Newman's
movies but from what I remember he was a
good good actor counter now we got John
Wick up here but then we got Keanu
Reeves down over here so we're talking
about the person the actor
and I happen to like Keanu Reeves he has
a very nice uh Motorcycle Company
hand-built bikes
um
what are they called somebody will put
in the chat but I was I was watching a
build show Once on YouTube where they
kind of like dove into this Workshop
he's got a very good Network he's very
well connected he's a nice guy and
um he definitely gets stuff done great
actor too
um you know he's acting a lot of a lot
of different stuff but I wouldn't call
him a sigma because he's got because
he's got a great Network right like you
know it's it's clear that these guys are
not lone wolves going their own way
Satoshi Nakamoto okay you might have me
I think you might be right who knows
it could be a a group of of people we
still don't know Bruce Willis
um Brad Pitt
um
I don't know
this guy uh yeah we'll give it to Ryan
sure
uh nobody knows any of them because
they're lone wolves they don't talk or
deal with anyone they're on their own
path well you know by that case our
friend Ryan you know collaborates with
quite a few people so maybe he's not
um
all flowers what kind of roles okay
Batman or his Hemingway Steve McQueen
Will Chamberlain
mushaki Steve McQueen
Steven Seager Cobra Tate definitely not
Andrew Tate he's he's like
if you know anything about Andrew he's
got a lot of friends right he's got a
network you know like I've got my
community Andrew's got his community
colleges the War Room whatever so you
know
if you've got a tribe if you've got a
gang that you that you roll with you
know sort of thing then that would
disqualify you from that definition
they don't exist see that's the that's
the common notion that gets that does
get pushed around you know quite a bit
it's just a made-up term for Alphas
without friends you know is what I've
heard
uh Henry Cavill yeah perhaps perhaps
Sean Connery
didn't know him well enough outside of
the films but I saw a few interviews
with Sean Connery
um
I don't know
Genghis Khan sorry is that Genghis or
Genesis Khan Muhammad Julius Caesar
Hannibal Teddy Roosevelt Alexander the
Great how would you know if Alexander
the Great was
a segment now he rolled with a big ass
Army so he had a tribe he had a gang so
no definitely not John F Kennedy
president of the United States no
he had an entire cabinet of people that
were rolling with him David Goggins
maybe he's like one of the things I
learned about Goggins is that he doesn't
really like to do uh podcasts he doesn't
like to do interviews he's very very
selective uh about putting you know
putting himself out there so perhaps yes
but he does have a powerful network of
friends I mean you know he's friends
with guys like Joe Rogan right
Mel Gibson Keanu Reeves bill Mayer
do you realize alpha male has debunked
in Wolf World male and female
co-dominate pack
um this guy's not too bright he's
probably one of those people that watch
that um
who's that fat guy he's a comedian you
try to demo debunk the alpha male
Terence mannon Don Draper James Bond
James Bond but no
no I mean he operated by himself but he
had a I mean he had Q he had the entire
tribe that would build all of his cool
gadgets and [__]
um he in most of the films would
collaborate with at least a few other
people
um very rarely operating Always by
himself but close yeah for sure
data not found Will Smith definitely
Will Smith's just a beta he's just a
he's just a nerd he's just not he's just
not there
I don't know if his career is ever going
to come back after that slap Jordan
Peterson if Sigma and Alpha qualities
were met in the middle
look I
whenever I talk about Jordan Peterson
right or I hear that name it's like um
because he does a lot of good you know
and he's definitely not
does yeah okay so let's solicit this
does he operate independently no
he's always collaborating with people
doing podcasts he signed up for the
daily water wire I don't know what they
paid him but if it's close to Stephen
Crowder's deal quite a bit of money
probably
he's well off
I wouldn't call him a sigma
I call him an alpha male
some some guys clearly might
not by my standards I mean
I I don't know you guys tell me what you
think of the chat
I like the guy look I like the guy it's
just some of the stuff that he said and
done just it's like
like his I did a three-part sorry not a
three-part series but there was a
three-part series that was on uh daily
wire plus I'm subscribed to that I went
there to go watch it and I did a
breakdown and unplugged out the podcast
series and his advice on marriage
horrible you can go watch that just it's
about a it's about a month back just go
for a search on uh the unplugged Alpha
and the Jordan Peterson plus marriage
you know you'll find it
personally I grouped them into singers
Alphas Sigma betas
Cliff High he'll know he'll know what
you're looking for who's this guy
uh uh never heard of him
Bryant this guy is a total nerd I would
not give him any credit at all
Elon Musk Elon Musk absolutely not why
how could Elon Musk be a sigma male he
started by building
um
I mean I mean his breakout was PayPal
which you know he did with like the
Silicon Valley crowd obviously
um every single business he's run has
not been a company of one it's been
large companies with lots of people
um you know you look at SpaceX how many
[__] people are employed there
Engineers rocket scientists blah blah
blah you know Tesla solar panels boring
company digging giant holes you know
massive holes in the Earth
um pretty much every company he's run is
not a company of one not a signal mail
whatsoever no leader of leader of a
large gang huge tribe and the people
that follow him outside of that that are
customers like if there's one thing that
you'll notice about
like people that buy musk's products
which is mostly Tesla is they they are
rabid fans of the product like they
absolutely love it
right so he's so he's built that part of
his Network too
uh Sigma male sounds like a cope but I
would say Daniel Day-Lewis yeah okay
Sigma males are a poor man's Alpha
that's interesting
they don't really exist but act as a
cope addition to the social sexual
hierarchy
Bobby Fisher
introvert yeah that's what we kind of
arrived at earlier is that it's an
introverted Alpha to some degree Jack
Donovan nope I Know Jack he's got a
tribe of men uh you know he's got his
own gang so
um I don't think he would call himself a
signal I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the
full-length podcast you can find that
over here that clips from if you're new
to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out